the combination of the animatronics and
the computer generator effects gives a
reality to the most extraordinary unreal
things it's there and it's happening i
saw them working on that it was
something it certainly was for me
it brings you know a small amount of
discomfort well that got the heart rate
up
we had to lock that design before we
shot it so you know a lot of times
movies of this size you're able to do
things in post-production you don't
really have to commit to design until
later but we built an animatronic
giganotosaurus so we didn't have the
benefit of figuring that out in post
the initial concepts were done by kevin
jenkins which was really a 2d
illustration at that point then they
would create these amazing scale clay
sculpts which kevin then scanned and
brought into the computer and did
digital models of it at that point we
would then hand those models to ilm who
took them and added extra detail and
scales we built physical skeletons to go
inside those dinosaurs to make sure that
they were anatomically correct and we
gave those models to john nolan who 3d
printed them at one to one scale
you